in styles it has an advice column and a  woman wrote in to say it bothers her  that her boyfriend likes bikini photos  of other women on instagram  not famous bikini models but you know  just everyday women who are posing in  bikinis online that he actually knows  he's liking their photos so here's oh he  knows even worse yeah right  yeah so isn't it i mean is it okay is it  okay uh i'll take this first dana um i  think if you have a girlfriend or wife  it is rude and those likes are to get  attention it's like morse code like like  like like  like you're just trying to communicate  and you want them to  maybe  uh notice you and that's that's a tough  that's a tough one to defend i would say